univers c'est plutôt grand le plus drôle
c'est que chaque créature qui y vit
occupe son propre petit monde productif
par exemple une fille comme les autres
avec une mère qu'il aime et un chat
nommé par qui elle ne se serait jamais
douté qu'à un million de kilomètres se
trouvait un bonhomme solitaire nommé aux
sarries modeste membres d'une race
nomades appelé les bouffes fait à la
recherche d'une planète accueillante où
s'installer sur quelles plantes ou ses
jolis fruits savoureux
ces deux là n'avaient aucune chance de
se rencontrer mais l'univers est tout
sauf prévisible
tu me libère pas alors je tirerai sur
toit d'un rayon laser avec mes yeux tu
as des lasers dans les yeux oui je suis
disposé à accepter de tapper un de vos
gestes traditionnels d'expression de la
gratitude de la tradition veut qu'on se
cale sur l'année tu vas voir tu attitude
est évident
par les créateurs des croûtes ton
véhicule et te fais c'est et aimons ça
voilà qu'il émet des vibrations va pas
exploser et de drago comment tu
t'appelles mes amis ma festif et moi oh
oh j'ai été donné ce nom par mes
nombreux nombreux amis bonjour
ils sont insaisissables
pourquoi ils cherchent comme ça j'ai les
fabriquer quelques bêtises à sion
auxerre était ce flou ils sont
incontrôlables qui se passe que fait mon
corps ça s'appelle danser je balance
mais en l'air comme si j'en avais rien à
perdre et leur voyage où tout le monde
le sait montaut de conduire
viendra inoubliable
car je le redis couvert notre voiture
en train d'essayer de me rendre compte
dreamworks animation présente en route
prochainement